حسنًا، لقد أمضى ضيفي التالي سنوات في
العمل من أجل حقوق الإنسان، بما في ذلك في
غزة، لكنه استقال الأسبوع الماضي من منصبه في
الأمم المتحدة احتجاجًا على ما
أسماه الإبادة الجماعية التي تتكشف ضد
الشعب الفلسطيني. وكان كريغ مكا
مديرًا لمكتب مفوضية
الأمم المتحدة السامية في نيويورك.  مفوض حقوق الإنسان أه
رأيته سابقا في تقرير سلمى
أه أه فولكا تورك سنناقش استقالة أم كريج
قبل لحظة من قيامنا
بذلك يا سيدي أم في تلك الرحلة إلى
معبر رفا رئيسك السابق
المفوض السامي لحقوق الإنسان قال كلا
الجانبين  لقد ارتكب الطرفان
جرائم حرب كما رددت أه دعوات
لوقف فوري لإطلاق النار بين إسرائيل وحماس
أكثر من ذلك من رئيس
أه وكالة الأمم المتحدة لحقوق الإنسان أو
خطوة أولى على الأقل من فولات ترك
نحو تغيير موقف الوكالة
أفكارك جيدًا أعتقد أنها
خطوة مهمة وأعتقد أنه من حق الدعوة إلى
التطبيق المتساوي للقانون الدولي
على جميع الأطراف المشتبه في
ارتكابهم جرائم حرب ما رأيناه
حتى هذه اللحظة هو مطالبة AAR
بالمحاسبة على جرائم الحرب أه
محتمل  ما ارتكبته حماس في
هجومها يوم 7 تشرين الأول (أكتوبر)
صحيح، أي عضو في حماس
متورط في جرائم حرب أو أي شخص
أمر بها يجب أن يحاسب
بموجب سيادة القانون، لكن ما
سمعناه في أحسن الأحوال حتى هذه اللحظة هو
الهمس للمطالبة بالمحاسبة على
جرائم الحرب الإسرائيلية وجرائم ضد
الإنسانية والتطهير العرقي والإبادة الجماعية
قبل 7 أكتوبر والكثير من
الهمس للمحاسبة على هذه
الجرائم أه التي ترتكبها إسرائيل منذ
7 أكتوبر القانون الدولي لحقوق الإنسان
والقانون الإنساني الدولي والجنائي الدولي
واضح جدا وينطبق
لجميع الجهات الفاعلة وواجب جميع
الدول الأعضاء في الولايات المتحدة والأمم المتحدة نفسها هو
العمل من أجل مساءلة
الجناة وإنصاف الضحايا
بغض النظر عمن هو الجاني
ومن هو الضحية، وكان ذلك جزءًا من
شكواي إلى الأمم المتحدة.  لقد رأيت
جوًا من الخوف في الأمم المتحدة حيث
كان هناك تردد في القيام بذلك مع
الدول القوية وأريد أن أتحدث عن ذلك في
لحظة أم لأن
استقالتك كانت على نطاق واسع أه تم الإبلاغ عنها
جزئيًا في خطاب استقالتك الذي قال إن
هذا كتاب مدرسي  قضية الإبادة الجماعية،
دخل المشروع الاستعماري الاستيطاني القومي الأوروبي في فلسطين
مرحلته النهائية نحو
التدمير السريع لآخر
بقايا الحياة الفلسطينية الأصلية
في
فلسطين، وقد حصلت هذه الرسالة على مجموعة واسعة
من الردود، بعضها أشاد
بقرارك، والبعض الآخر وصفه بأنه علني
معاداة السامية ردك،
نعم، نحن على دراية بهذا
التكتيك المتمثل في اتهام الأشخاص بمعاداة
السامية إذا تجرأوا على التنديد
بالانتهاكات الإسرائيلية ضد الفلسطينيين،
وهو تكتيك منتشر
وكان لفترة طويلة
ويفسر جزئيًا  الخوف الذي
ترونه في المنظمات الدولية
لا أحد يريد أن يُطلق عليه اسم معاد للسامية،
لكنني قدمت القضية وما زلت
أطرح القضية بأن انتقاد
الانتهاكات الإسرائيلية لحقوق الإنسان ليس
معاديًا للسامية أكثر من انتقاد
انتهاكات السعودية السادسة باعتباره كراهية للإسلام أو معاداة للإسلام.
منتقد ISM للانتهاكات البورمية هو
مناهض للبوذية أو انتقاد
الانتهاكات الهندية هو مناهض للهندوسية، إذا كان كل
هذا صحيحًا، فلا يوجد
إطار دولي لحقوق الإنسان، ولكن
إذا كان مجرد حظر على
انتقاد إسرائيل بشكل جيد، فهذا
اقتراح عنصري لأنه  يعني أن
الفلسطينيين وحدهم لا يحق لهم
الدفاع عن حقوقهم الإنسانية، وأشير
إلى الآلاف من
المدافعين اليهود عن حقوق الإنسان
ونشطاء السلام والأشخاص الرئيسيين في جميع أنحاء العالم
الذين يقفون في مسيرة
ويسيطرون على محطة غراند سنترال
وتمثال الحرية  جعل
أصواتهم مسموعة في جميع القارات
قائلين إن هذا ليس باسمهم، إنهم
لا يدعمون هذا، إسرائيل لا
تمثلهم، وفي الواقع، من
المجازات القديمة المعادية للسامية الإشارة إلى أن
انتقاد إسرائيل هو بطريقة ما
انتقاد لليهود، إسرائيل دولة  فهي، مثل
كل الآخرين، مسؤولة عن
جرائمها، وهذه المسؤولية لا
تمتد إلى إخواننا وأخواتنا اليهود
في أي مكان